[Música]
callejón cuestiones a la adhesión
qué tal buenas tardes quería preguntarle
si alguien ha estado en china si habla
chino las manos por favor
muy bien creo que el número es optimista
espero que la próxima vez que venga si
hay ocasión estos suba y que la mayoría
de la sala haya estado ching en china o
que sepa hablar en chino pues hoy me
gustaría compartir un descubrimiento
personal que me parece muy interesante
porque es aplicable tanto en las
personas como en las empresas que salen
de su país de origen para irse a otro a
otra cultura otro entorno desconocido
y que allí ha encontrado la forma de
seguir adelante y de adaptarse y hablo
de dos niveles de resiliencia en este
caso por una parte la adaptación que es
una necesidad y por otra parte la
integración que según mi entendimiento
es una elección como dijo darwin
no es el más inteligente ni el más
fuerte el que sobrevive sino el que
mejor se adapta al cambio pues en mi
caso quería compartir con ustedes cómo
fue la adaptación cuando vine de china a
españa con mis padres tenemos que
remontarnos a los años 90 cuando tenía
12 años nunca había salido de mi pueblo
y en el mundo en un momento en el que
las el desconocimiento entre china y
españa era casi total recuerdo todavía a
mi vecina cuando llegamos a sevilla nos
vino con los brazos abiertos con una
sonrisa en la cara y nos dio dos besos
sonoros a la cara imagínense no
lo que supuso de impacto para una niña
de 12 años recién salida de china a la
que educaron pues de mantener la calma
de no exteriorizar sus emociones pues
aparte de esa anécdota a otro reto para
mí supuso pues por ser la hija de unos
inmigrantes tuve que trabajar aparte de
estudiar tuve que echar una mano en el
negocio familiar eso supuso que no tenía
apenas tiempo para relacionarme o de
ocio
pero bueno con el carácter muy cálido de
mi segunda tierra sevilla y con el apoyo
familiar de mis padres que quisieron que
siguiera a mis estudios conseguí
adaptarme paulatinamente pero muy bien
y vengo a hablar hoy aparte de la
adaptación que creo que es una necesidad
como dije antes la integración
como una elección de las personas
como este que mal y aunque ven en la
imagen
supo ir un paso más allá
de la mera adaptación para transformarse
e integrarse en el nuevo entorno
pues en el caso mío la transformación
fue un proceso largo y difícil porque
salí de mi zona de confort y emprendí mi
propio camino un camino no recorrido por
mis padres por lo que no tenía un modelo
de referencia a seguir
sin embargo fue bastante gratificante
porque supuso una apertura al nuevo
mundo nuevo entorno y eso me dio una
importante elección en el sentido de que
hay que aceptar la situación la nueva
situación y hay que también
e intentar que en los retos que se te
vengan superarlos ya eso me voy con esa
fase de superación e integración
en el aparte del camaleón en el mundo
humano relaciono esa integración con las
personas que son capaces de moverse en
ese entorno totalmente desconocido
y a dar ese paso más allá de la mera
transformación de la mera adaptación esa
transformación no tiene por qué suponer
una ruptura con la cultura anterior ni
ni ni una
y una pérdida de esencia de uno mismo
pero si una aceptación una actitud
positiva y una asimilación profunda de
la nueva cultura
recuerdo que en mi caso tuve
tuve esa confrontación de valores
después de un período en españa' y
recuerdo que tuve una crisis de
identidad cuando no supe contestar a mis
amigos que si me sentía más china
hombres española
y no paraba de preguntar a cada amigo
con el que me encontraba si me veía de
una forma o de otra hasta que una amiga
un día me tranquilizó con su respuesta y
me dijo lisa
yo creo que no eres tiempo decía en
china ni cien por cien española pero la
suma de las dos identidades dentro de ti
es más que el 100%
y dije wow tenía que haber hablado con
ella antes desde entonces no me
importaba que la gente me hiciera esta
pregunta pues creo que mi experiencia es
extrapolable a las empresas que salen de
su país para abrir mercado por ejemplo a
china estas empresas tuvieron que
afrontar los mismos retos como los míos
un mercado desconocido barreras de
idioma barreras culturales diferencias
de gestión etcétera algunas se adaptaron
y otras consiguieron ir un paso más allá
para transformarse
e integrarse en ese entorno tan
desconocido volviéndose cada vez más
flexibles lleno y en eso según mi
opinión consiste la resiliencia en
nuestras capacidades de asumir con
flexibilidad nuevas situaciones adversas
adaptándonos e integrándonos para salir
de ellas
fortalecidos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]